from for me mainstreamed it's not
necessarily negative because when I grew
up mainstream films in the 70s were
critically lauded and popular you know
when it in the theater there'd be
Godfather movies network Nashville and
you know these were popular movies were
mainstream movies Cuckoo's Nest and mash
and these were all very iconic plastic
films that and often what would be
considered now art films and independent
films on bigger budgets starring major
stars that looked like us these people
looked like us as opposed to now where
stars are you know really kind of
royalty or aliens and they look that way
so to me I never I never separated
popular from good you know and because
of economics I think it has separated so
it's rare for me to go to a Hollywood
film unless I really get recommendations
from people i know because i just so
disappointed usually when it's so much
money is being spent you tend to have a
go for the lowest common denominator in
terms of quality but there is a you know
doing the rabbit hole really was the
budget was less than head big it just
happened to have major stars in it and
there's no distributor or studio
involved putting on commercial pressures
it was just the producers who have a
mainstream understanding and holly live
in Hollywood but I definitely had good
taste so in a way Lou with rabbit hole
we're trying to make the kind of
that was a small a quiet film about real
people that was common in the late 70s
and early 80s as a mainstream film you
know like a ordinary people or Kramer vs
Kramer or shoot the moon or any number
of serious minded but mainstream film
with with mainstream stars which is
unusual right now